bien sûr et heureusement ce vendredi
soir il n'y a pas eu de mort mais le
traumatisme est profond si la terre a
fortement tremblé en Charente-Maritime
résonant jusque dans les Deux Sèvres
disons le simplement ce sont des vies
qui ont vaciller
environ 250 maisons inhabitables 500
personnes directement impactées sur
place le lendemain j'ai rencontré des
habitants choqués et inquiets en proie
ou doute et aux questions ou quand
comment où seront-ils relogés quand
seront-ils indemnisés et à quelle
hauteur comment seront-ils accompagnés
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
ministre il est essentiel que nous
prenions tous la mesure de cette
catastrophe afin d'agir au plus vite
Gérald Darmanin annoncé une procédure
accélérée de recrudescence de
catastrophes naturelles monsieur le
ministre Klein vous êtes rendu hier avec
Christophe Béchu sur les communes les
plus sinistrées au nom des habitants et
des parlementaires concernés je vous
remercie
saluez nos pompiers et nos gendarmes qui
sont une nouvelle fois exemplaires
souligner l'élan de solidarité qui s'est
immédiatement mis en place et remercier
aussi les maires les élus et les agents
communaux qui font un travail
exceptionnel pour recenser les sinistres
et répondre autant que possible à la
détresse des habitants ils ont besoin de
la solidarité nationale
aujourd'hui et demain car nous rentrons
dans une période de temps long désormais
les maisons doivent être sécurisées les
personnes sinistrées doivent être
relogées à long terme dans des logements
décents sur un territoire déjà en
tension immobilière
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
détailler les actions que l'État va
mettre en place et notamment le
dispositif de fond d'aide au relogement
d'urgence je vous remercie